I've always had that dream, like my daddy before me.
So I started writing songs, I started writing stories.
Something about that glory just always seemed to bore me.
'Cause only those I truly love will ever really know me.
Once I was 20 years old, my story got told.
Before the morning sun, when life was lonely.
Once I was 20 years old.
I only see my goals, I don't believe in failure.
'Cause I know the smallest voices, they can make it major.
I got my boys with me, at least those in favor.
And if we don't meet before I leave, I hope I'll see you later.
Once I was 20 years old, my story got told.
I was writing about everything I saw before me.
Once I was 20 years old.